no it's not enough yo - you promised me
power you said if I get a lot of
dislikes I will get more views I will
become more powerful than ever
yes yes of course I'm still the most
powerful youtuber on the planet I don't
think you understand
I need MA I don't think you understand
the excessive greed of a youtuber I know
you're holding out on me YouTube
tell me what to tell secrets do you have
that can effect the algorithm I did
their likes and did the dislikes of
course I'm gonna melt this [ __ ] [ __ ]
what else you got what [ __ ] died 1
million German John we [ __ ] million
comments can we smash it
1 million comments 1 million governments
will put this play 1 million 1 million
god
everybody let's smash one willing to
comment on this video
yeah one mailing comes I will delete my
channel dick pics at 1 million comments
2017 hashtag let's trend it worldwide
vodka 1 million comments I'll kill
myself abuse
1 million
one melon come did you come again have
you left
[Music]
failure
open your eyes
[Music]
and what what you people actually
comment hey I got an idea
why don't we just add a picture with
shitty me kids love that [ __ ]
they comment like crazy it's [ __ ]
morons
[Music]